car tester Reinhold Eisenhower is amazed
at how quickly time flies it's already
been five years since outtie debuted its
new q3 at the time it was the only rival
for BMW x1 in the meantime the lineup of
premium SUVs has grown considerably
Mercedes has enter the race and even
Jaguar has rolled out a premium SUV even
so the q3 series has been a best-seller
for Audi in an effort to build on its
success Audi has given the compact
crossover SUV a facelift we've had they
known that reinholt is going to try out
the dynamic sport and efficiency modes
the suspension can be set to any one of
the three with Drive select the drive
select set ski handling characteristics
according to individual taste for
instance the optional adaptive
suspension it combines nimble handling
with advanced safety features we tested
the most powerful diesel offered for the
q3 with a 135 kilowatt output and an S
tronic 7-speed dual-clutch transmission
on both front and rear horizontal lines
emphasize the q3 s broad shoulders
howdies designers have refined the coupe
eight lines and the characteristically
sleek wraparound tailgate the s-line
sports package on the car we tested made
for a nicely dynamic impression inside
and out the nineteen hundred euro charge
for the trim includes the three spoke
leather sports steering wheel
the seats hug driver and passenger like
those of a racy sports car the back
seats have room for three passengers but
the 460 liters of cargo space is a bit
on the small side remote islands and
plastics reinhold says the engines are
powerful but efficient his only
criticism is that from the side the
taillights look somehow off-kilter but
the well integrated headlights make up
for that in Germany the q3 starts at
about thirty thousand euros the RS q3 is
a bit sportier it's two and a half liter
TFSI engine puts out 250 kilowatts and
leaves from 0 to 100 kilometers an hour
in 4.8 seconds